another another moment that you went
viral for is um you know when they had
Hard Knocks and everybody asked you know
your teammates and the Vikings who would
who would they least like to date their
sister and everybody everybody was
unanimous and they said Diggs
I think they was hating too though I
said I think they was hating because
back then that Team bro that Team bro I
could have picked some of those guys and
I didn't like my phone was like what am
I I think I was just an easy target
right here man don't believe those guys
those guys are liars only person that's
a good guy right there that they're
showing is somewhat Adam I'm feeling
yeah for sure that's my God on this
bill's team like oh I love them who
would who would you which which I would
say Let me let me write this way which
bill would you allow today's your sister
I want to do rather not but who's a
presume good God on his team
I don't know
not not uh I gave Davis
I
need somebody to go to go to mass on
before the game and stuff I mean I've
been around Dawson Knox Dawson's not bad
right oh ready to get him Reggie oh man
he's good he's selling me now I think uh
you know Tommy Doyle is cool yeah it
does look like Tommy duel I like Mitch
Morris yo give me Mrs Gray I love
Mitchell that's Mitch's body we don't
even refer to him as a mitch give me no
give me give me who you at least
uh I mean besides you and myself you
know I'm sure like I'm sure they say I'm
sure they say me or you on there I would
probably go probably Isaiah man like
Isaiah
McKenzie no I just wouldn't do it bro
I'm sure me and you would probably lead
those like lists but I wouldn't like you
know if I had to pick like I wouldn't
you know I've been around Isaiah on two
different teams and he's the same guy
that's not good
you know I wouldn't I wouldn't let
Isaiah do it for sure I'm telling a
little dirty I can't wait down